في تطورات العمليه العسكريه التركيه شمالي
سوريا افادت مصادر محليه للجزيره بان
الجيش التركي المتمركز في قواعده بمناطق
المعارضه شمالي وغربي سوريا استهدف مواقع
لما تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه في
تلجمعه بمحيط تلتمر بريف الحسكه واوضحت
المصادر وان الطائرات المسيره التركيه
حلقت لساعات في سماء مدينه الملكيه وعين
عيسى بريف الحسكه وصرين بريف حلب كما
تعرضت مواقع ما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه لقصف بالاسلحه الثقيله
والمدفعيه التركيه بقريتي الهوشان والدبس
ومحيط الطريق الدولي اند فور شمال الرقه
وفي قرى زورما غار وجرق لي وشيوخ بريف عين
العرب على الحدود السوريه
[موسيقى]
في غضون ذلك اكدت مصادر تركيه للجزيره ان
وفد روسيا عرض على تركيا انسحابه مقاتلين
ما تعرف بقوه سوريا الديمقراطيه مع
اسلحتهم من عين العرب ومنبج واضافه
المصادر التركيه للجزيره ان العرض الروسي
يقترح الابقاء على قوات الاسايش الكرديه
بعد دمجها في المؤسسه الامنيه للنظام وان
الوفد الروسي ابلغ الجانب التركي موافقه
ما تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه على هذا
المقترح شريطه الضمان عدم حصول اجتياح
تركيه كما قالت المصادر التركيه للجزيره
ان انقره تدرس المقترحات التي قدمها الوفد
الروسي ولا تزال في مرحله النقاش بشانها